hello and welcome to the agenda from a
rather murky brussels breast not putting
off shoppers at this market
last week meps voted through the first
stage of the banking union the single
supervisory mechanism but many obstacles
still remain cue stage 2 the single
resolution mechanism winding down
failing banks president of the ecb mario
draghi who attends monday's economic and
monetary affairs committee meeting
supports it but some member states not
so much it should make for an
interesting discussion
did the nsa hack home wi-fi and the
swift network
these were some of the many claims made
at the civil liberties committee's
inquiry into data surveillance
brazil the latest country to join the
row after his president canceled a
meeting with president barack obama on
wednesday back here in europe edward
snowden has been nominated for this
year's sakura prize as the saga
continues more revelations are expected
at the next meeting on tuesday
political agreement on cap reforms was
reached months ago but budget wrangling
means that it's holding up
implementation and creating uncertainty
for the industry discussions between
parliament member states and the
commission are ongoing hopefully they
can iron out any outstanding issues
leaving the agricultural committee free
to vote on the cap reform package on
monday 30 september and as i said last
week first there was a pip breast
implant scandal and then we learned that
a french manufacturer of hip replacement
cerave had sold non-certified prosthetic
limbs to french hospitals preventing
another pip disaster will be top of the
agenda as parliament's health committee
will vote on a draft report on medical
devices on wednesday and that's all we
have for this agenda take care and enjoy
the week